president trump chose not to mention the
painful toll of the 200 000
number that david just told us about
during a campaign rally near pittsburgh
last night
as ben tracy reports he defended his
response to the pandemic
and then mocked the public health
measure used by tens of millions of
americans including
his democratic opponent we're talking
about mask
in the debate it'll be him and i on the
stage is he going to walk in with a mask
as the country reached a once
unthinkable milestone
more than 200 000 dead in the united
states
president trump made fun of joe biden
for wearing a mask
something proven to slow the spread of
the virus i mean honestly what the hell
did he spend all that money on the
plastic surgery if he's going to cover
it up with a bus
at a large and largely maskless rally in
pittsburgh tuesday night
he praised his administration's response
to the pandemic
our early and aggressive actions saved
millions of lives
but the president only commented on the
staggering death toll earlier at the
white house
when pressed by reporters well i think
it's a shame
i think if we didn't do it properly and
do it right
you'd have two and a half million deaths
but former vice president joe biden
accused the president of making the
pandemic worse
tweeting it didn't have to be this bad
and his running mate
senator kamala harris accused president
trump of downplaying the virus
when he knew it was deadly with this
knowledge went on to call this virus a
hoax
went on to suggest that we should
dismiss
what the public health professionals
were telling us
last night president trump once again
claimed there will soon be a vaccine
we'll develop and distribute a vaccine
very very shortly in record time
but according to the washington post the
fda is actually going to tighten its
restrictions for approving a coronavirus
vaccine that could make the president's
timeline
unlikely there is some good news however
on the vaccine front here in the u.s
a fourth large-scale coronavirus vaccine
trial
is entering phase three testing on
adults this one is promising because it
hopes to provide protection with one
dose
versus two tony that is good news ben
thank you very much